North Korean leader Kim Jong-un says US
policy towards the Korean Peninsula is
making War inevitable Kim was speaking
at an end ofe Workers Party meeting in
pongyang he said deployment of US
military Assets in the region had turned
South Korea into an American Military
Base Kim also announced he'll no longer
pursue reconciliation and reunification
with South Korea blaming defense tires
between soul and Washington here is
Unice Kim with more from
so North Korean State media posting a
lengthy statement essentially in
capturing a five-day key political party
meeting that wrapped in Pyongyang which
covered everything from the economy to
military goals in the new year and the
food situation but what's uh what's
catching the eyes of those in South
Korea is North Korea ruling out a
peaceful
reunification uh saying that a military
usurpation is the only viable option now
Kim Jong-un the leader of North Korea is
quoted at characterizing the nature of
relations between South and North Korea
as uh no longer that of kin or of blood
but of two hostile countries two
belligerant at War also saying soul is a
colonized State under Washington Reliant
for its security and National Defense
kcna also uh signaling three new
satellite launches in 2024 drone
production and other preparation for
what it views as inevitable war on the
peninsula now since the Korean Peninsula
was divided some seven decades ago
there's been various scenarios put on
the table for a peaceful
reunification but since denuclearization
talks in 2019 broke down under then US
president Donald Trump and leader Kim
jong-in in Hanoi communication have
basically also been at a halt with soul
with Pyongyang and we're also seeing
signs of North Korea tightening its grip
on North Koreans accessing any outside
South Korean dramas for example content
of passing out death sentences for
watching that so with this morning's
announcement it appears that North Korea
is further solidifying and formalizing
its distance and Detachment from South
Korea Unis Kim aljazera
Soul I'm joined Now by INB Chan a former
South Korean Special Forces commander
who is live for us from Soul thank you
very much sir for being on Al jaera
first of all as we heard there Kim's
warned war is inevitable and ordered the
military to prepare accordingly I mean
how concerning is this or is it just
pure posturing from Kim at this
point well from what I've seen from my
experience North Korea is not new to to
harsh words and
rhetoric but it is quite concerning that
Kim jungan himself has made these very
strong and harsh comments so it's
unavoidable that the tensions on the
Korean Peninsula will be a little bit
more High than usual at at this point in
time what is North Korea's military
actually capable of producing of of
doing not Korea has a large military but
we've seen that uh
quantity uh does have its faults when
you lack quality this uh statement by
Kim Jun could be a first step to try to
make sure that his military is more
capable and ready because they've been
suffering from lack of resources and
funds although they've been uh focusing
on missiles and Rockets So this could be
a push for his so his generals to focus
more on Readiness yeah I mean for a
country that is seemingly so isolated
how is it actually able to produce and
manufacture such sophisticated
Weaponry uh what can I say North Koreans
are not stupid they seem to have an
international uh connection with um
other countries and they've been
focusing all of their resources on
weapons and they've been quite
successful yeah well what um Kim's also
announced he's not going to pursue any
further reconciliation or reunification
with South Korea I mean was there ever a
real chance of that happening under his
leadership well the North Koreans have
always said that the Korean people are
one that we identify ourselves as a a
one people he's basically said that
although we are still one people that
the South Koreans are puppets of
capitalism especially the United States
and he has given up dealing with the
South Koreans peacefully so this is a
very U uh a new type of
uh uh approach that the North Korean
government has decided and declared
given all of this you mentioned that uh
tension is obviously going to rise uh
where you are what do you think is going
to happen
next anything can happen uh we have 155
miles of uh
territorial uh area that uh the armis is
maintained and further to that we have
an extension along our
Coast uh which We call we referred to as
the northern limit line where hundreds
of ships uh come in close proximity and
so both sides need to be very careful
that unintentional clashes do not occur
the Kim has also vowed to put three new
military spy satellites into orbit in
2024 as we've seen there have been major
issues with uh with doing that over the
last year or so but I believe that one
was uh successful in November how
successful do you think uh next year
2024 is going to be for uh the North
Korean uh missile
program well I'm sorry to say that if I
were a betting man I would probably say
that the North Koreans will probably
succeed in uh pursuing those other
satellites but I must remind the world
that this so-called satellite technology
is the same as uh International uh
intercontinental ballistic missile
technology that's why we're so worried
okay thank you so much uh for your time
and your Insight we really do appreciate
it that's inur former South Korean
Special Forces Commander thank
you thank you